before the show I'll say kima Kenzie and
fake it prepares something to welcome my
first guest and now that they're both
officially cheerleaders
this can be your first official cheer
y'all ready you ready okay okay whenever
you're ready just do your thing get that
high kick in there Ayana stretch first
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
oh my god I they had something they had
something blocking the entrance to be
honest with you a lot of children
families watch this at home
paper cuts are dangerous if you can
avoid a paper cut they do it's so
dangerous it is so dangerous and that is
amazing the father and daughter thing I
know I was gonna say I've been
researching you and like I've kids so
they're really into tik-tok a couple of
them and you're really in a tick tock
you have all these videos i love tick
tock
is anybody here on tick tock okay I'll
take that as a no no but there are
millions of people so the talk is the
you know they used to be vine yeah and a
lot of people are on Instagram and phase
but tick tock is 15 seconds yeah 15
seconds better me magical right but but
the point is I can't concentrate for
nine so if something's that's short and
that exciting I'm into it but on that on
that the kids they'd a lip sync and they
dance and they and I love lip syncing
and dancing but so I love doing that and
then millions of people they watch me
dance and they learned from my moves I
do I have some tic TOCs I brought some
let's see okay let's see one
[Music]
[Applause]
yes that's Heidi Klum that's like over
25 million views I know I know and 24
million of them are me but the thing
Heidi Klum I'm dancing with Heidi Klum
not only am i dancing with honey Klum
I'm thrilled as you know Heidi Klum is
back on a GT champion oh I love her
you know she she left her season because
she had to go do some big stuff all over
the world but I love Heidi Klum I told
her as a judge and I am a judge of
talent and I do it professionally I took
one look at her and I said I swear I
said this to her you should model that's
what I said to her and the thing is I'm
able to look at somebody and identify
talent and she said and then she told me
I was I was right so wait what are you
planning next for tick-tock what are you
on tick-tock you I'm yes what you want
to do something together let's do one
let's try and beat 25 million views I
could do that okay you know if I can't
no no we could do it you know the yes no
that yes no one yep now let's do the yes
No
so we'll do the yes no we'll do it and
I'll post it right now and we'll post so
the yes note could be to any question we
could fill in whatever we want I already
am in okay so let's record it what
camera should we record what camera
should we look at we'll look right there
okay you ready okay okay I am ready you
got to play the music and we will use
the first one yes sir the first one No
[Music]
No yes okay you're amazing
so I just gotta tell her upload that
right now and at home you can go look at
tick-tock I'm gonna post it right now
we'll post it right now yeah at home
look at it and get us toward you guys
aren't allowed to take your phones out
so get us a twenty four million when you
go home you'll get the other million you
take their phones in the milk you know
what yeah can I be honest with you I'm
here for a little bit right yes I hope
so can I ask a question yes okay I have
to go I have to go to the bathroom I
know this is the men's room after
commercial okay it's actually commercial
what timing is that the bathroom like
really I gotta go my god I gotta go just
premiered and it's all champions right
it's America's Got Talent champions you
did it last year and we're doing it
again it's kind of the Olympics of
talent right so winners and runner-up
sand people who did good all over the
world because you know it's the biggest
the most the biggest show in the world
it's in a hundred and 50 markets you
know whether it's Japan's Got Talent
Romania's Got Talent all these so all
the winners and runner-up or people that
want to redeem themselves and get a
second chance come so it's the best of
the best and the winner of that is
champion of the world and he was crazy
won America's Got Talent and America's
Got Talent champions last year and he's
now got a residency in Vegas can we is
by far the best close-up magician I've
ever seen in my life and usually when
you're on those shows if you're sitting
close you can kind of I guess see
nothing he is truly a wizard truly
magical I love shinless I literally
think he has magic because I was like
how did you do that he's really good
really you have a favorite that's like
and of all the people that have been on
there do you have won it I do
okay whoo I do be unbeatable now the
unbeatable are these kids from Mumbai
these kids from Mumbai there's like 40
kids from Mumbai the range in age from 8
to 22 yeah lot summit most of them are
homeless or orphans they have nothing
together they have made their way to
America to our stage they were on a GT
this year I have never seen something
more exciting more dangerous more I
don't know if you ever got a chance to
see them but they they'll flip a kid two
stories in the air he'll flip around and
land with one foot on the top of a
bamboo pole then flip off and land on
some other people and it is so dangerous
so exciting so thrilling I have never
been on the edge of my seat like I am
for VN beetle I mean as a parent does it
make you nervous though because you're
like wait baby boy don't do that like I
don't have that accent can you imagine
me talk to you I really want you to hey
boy don't do that I'm gonna do that next
on the next episode watch every time
every time somebody jumps I'm gonna baby
boy don't do that I don't want you to
[Laughter]
think you might have people tied up in
your basement it's fine don't do that
[Laughter]
thank you thank you I'm gonna take that
as a compliment misery it's one of my
favorite shoes yes I see that you can
pull it off I can I can be I who knows
I'm the next Kathy Bates there you go
all your good okay I'm waiting as a
comedian I'm done I hold for the left
but as a talk show guest I'm holding
some questions for the clap I'm holding
whoa
how did you get it
[Applause]
I'm a happily married man 40 years
actually that was what I've been married
for 40 years now you met it 12 he
actually met there she is
that's my love we were both babies I had
hair I had hair and so did she
so but we met when we were young we met
like people get together now we met
online and yes we did we were online to
buy fries and she was in front of me and
I didn't have enough money and I bought
a quarter from her
I did absolutely true and I have been
[Laughter]
water and I gave her a lifetime of this
look at this your well look at this
prize I thought it was a prize now I go
home and I realized she's living with
Kathy Bates
you brought a clip of your wife actually
right I brought it well I did said they
asked me or your staff said what's it
like like marriage for 40 years how do
you make it interesting I don't know if
I make it interesting as I do annoying
and my wife I'll show you I brought this
clip because she got really mad at me
she did it was her birthday
and I wanted to surprise my wife my wife
loves animals any kind of animal she
does and we work for preserve and gives
them so I an elephant I've rented an
elephant I rented an elephant and I had
it brought to the house because it's a
big I wanted I love her know what I did
I did go big yeah but I'm not a good
planner and I have severe attention I
didn't invite anybody I didn't cater I
didn't bring even a staff so just like
an elephant showed up well let me show
you the video and then I'm gonna talk
about the trouble so this is my wife's
birthday watch what I did for my wife's
birthday watch this this is my wife's
birthday party that's my wife there's
the elephant
and there's my wife okay wait there's an
elephant have one balloon no I have
nothing and it's so stupid I don't think
it is and also because we care about
animals you can't just bring an animal
for an hour an animal he had to be like
out of the whatever the transport thing
for at least 12 hours yeah so the animal
was in our backyard for 12 hours so wait
wait and and I don't have that kind of
attention and my wife is bored after
half hours so we went in the house but
elephants they like palm trees so the
elephant took out all our palm trees
though elephant took him out and laid
them down and then the elephant how much
clearer can I make it so and then and
then the elephant needed to be
comfortable so they said I should hose
so I hosed the elephant which made it
muddy and then the elephant they're
heavy the elephant sunk into my lawn and
broke the sprinklers all the sprinklers
wait wait wait
and then we I ordered food not for us
but for the elephant the elephant ate
and then the elephant is very regular
the elephant is very regular oh my god
that's what the guy who came to our
backyard the next day said because there
are piles of elephant dung there so
there was the next day the gardener do
we have a gardener gardener came he
comes around the corner the the the yard
is these holes that are four feet deep
the sprinklers are broken five palm
trees are laying all over the place and
there's a pile of you can put a bleep on
right there's a pile yes there's a
there's a giant there is no and the guy
walks in and he goes mr. Mendell
what what is this and I go it was my
wife's birthday
I never explained there was $45,000
damage the sprinklers my the trees and
elephant poo removal is not a service
that is nearby
your gift to your wife for her birthday
was just severely pissing her off you
know what I'm consistent I'm fairly
consistent so it's not any different on
her birthday than it is each and every
day it's important to me you know what
she loves about me is that I'm here and
she's not a long time she gets a long
time without me
I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my YouTube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this